[Music]
tonight I am excited to announce the
next game from tango ghosts wire Tokyo
it is an action-adventure game in which
you will fight for a normal enemy and
the great city of a supernatural evil I
think you rabbit
to tell you more about ghost wire Tokyo
here is creative director at tango Akuma
Nakamura
[Applause]
[Music]
Wow so many people wow thank you are you
got the was I
[Applause]
such a such a big stage makes me nervous
I'll do my best to speaking English
we are making a new kind of
action-adventure game it's Turkey but
not the survivor holiday that we are not
for people are banishing in Tokyo you
must find out why you will encounter
conspiracies and the occult you have do
it you have to explore the world face
challenges to uncover the torus and save
humanity in the game you will meet
spirits somewhat dangerous some of these
worlds and survivor that each have their
stories you will need to ask yourself it
is normal or paranormal I ask myself
this question every time I go to the
office
just kidding just kidding just eating we
are very excited
let's take a look me tanner thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
don't fear the unknown
attack it
[Applause]